all right now we turn to one of the
worst parts of the left's cover 19
hysteria the hypocrisy you know while
many democratic governors and mayors and
school boards forcing your kids to wear
a mask all day long in school well the
same rules
don't seem to apply to elected
politicians there's gavin newsom yet
again
at the football game yesterday
surrounded by thousands of fans there he
is with magic johnson no mask and
despite his own universal mask mandate
oh and there's the mayor of los angeles
no mask yeah they have a mass mandate
there too here are all the other many
celebrities totally ignoring the mask
mandates keep in mind school kids in
california are the least likely to
become seriously ill from covert and yet
they're the ones being forced to wear
the masks not the politicians that put
the policies in place here with more the
author of the upcoming book here's the
deal kellyanne conway along with the
co-host of outnumbered kaylee mcenany
all right you're both moms here so i
want to look at it from the from a
mother's perspective you see these these
phony hypocrites kaylee by the way
congratulations kellyanne on the book
we'll talk about that um
and i'm like and then we we put our kids
in school all day they have to wear this
thing
yeah that's it i've seen kids on planes
we've all seen the videos of kids being
forced off of planes their parents as
well
because of these onerous mass mandates
two-year-olds three-year-old shawn i
have a two-year-old i can tell you
two-year-olds will not wear masks but
all you have to do if you want an
exemption from the mask mandate is go to
a swanky football game like gavin newsom
did go to a swanky dc book party like
anthony fauci did where he didn't wear
his mask he was pictured not wearing his
mask he was asked why are you wearing
his mask your mask and he said oh well i
put it up if i didn't know someone
that's called a sham excuse we have
sacrificed america's children on the
altar of coven 19. it is a shame while
the elites the swampy elites have gone
out and partied gone to football games
gone to restaurants and time after time
sean we've seen the hypocrisy we've
exposed it here on this show
by the way kellyanne the real reason
kelly and i wanted you on the show
tonight to see if if we made the cut and
and here's the deal are we in the book
at all
um
until you buy it i'll never tell it's
pre-sale now
i got to buy it to find out thanks a lot
you got it you got to read it and i hope
there's no index in it because people in
washington new york love to look for
their name first they think that's the
most important part of this book okay
that's the least important part trust me
all right there it is but speaking as a
mom as a parent
i mean yes
but my daughter's dealing with this guy
that's the most aggravating thing sean
the the the toughest thing about this
entire
covid debate as it rages on is really
what we're doing to the children i have
four school-age children middle school
and high school
and every day we wake up wondering if
we're going to get an email there is
school there isn't school stay home
don't stay home you're a close contact
wear a mask get vaccinated do one or the
other do both and then they turn on the
tv and they see hypocrisy and it's not
you know gavin newsom and magic johnson
i think it's funny because gavin newsom
doesn't really understand that you're
supposed to take the mask off if you're
drinking not lie about why you're not
wearing a mask because you have been
drinking he mistakes that mandate
completely and it wasn't just him at the
french laundry back in 2020 that caused
that very righteous uproar about him
locking down the whole state of
california and going out and having a
nice meal at a five-star restaurant with
people not in his household but what
about let's let's review does everybody
remember the mayor of denver the
democrat who literally recorded a saying
to constituents in denver saying please
shelter in place don't have thanksgiving
with your loved ones and then flew to
mississippi to join his wife and
daughter for thanksgiving um
rules for thee not for me then my
favorite of course was was the mayor who
the mayor of austin who recorded a video
telling people
not to go out or not to stay home and he
did it from cabo san lucas where he had
flown the night before so these are this
is democratic hypocrisy i think people
understand it the poll you quoted a
while ago sean before you had those
wonderful truckers on 70 according to
the monmouth poll today say that we
probably just have to get used to living
with covet and get on with our lives
they are willing to they are willing to
get used to covet they're not willing to
get used to joe biden and the way his
team handles covid
his numbers are still upside down
scathing knives out piece on his hhs
secretary today for quote not having
health experience and not having much of
a role even though we're in a global
pandemic so people know this they see
that and i think it's all reflecting the
numbers our kids the mental health
effects the isolation everything we're
doing to them that part bothers me the
most
and the fact that kayla i'll give you
the last word we've got about 30 seconds
joe biden runs out of tests after
christmas he runs out of monoclonal
antibodies um he
can't get the antivirals that they
didn't have a operation warp speed for
anything they learned nothing from
donald trump
yeah we in the trump administration left
joe biden the most advanced most
sophisticated testing system in the
modern world in the in western europe we
were out testing all of western europe
combined he destroyed it and he was
offered a plan as vanity fair said to
create 732 million coveted tests he
rejected it this guy's an utter and
complete failure it's why he has a 39
approval rating on kovid and his marks
are far lower on other issues
33 percent overall keep going joey
you're doing great uh all right we look
forward to kellyanne's book
uh kaylee had a great best-selling book
herself hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else